[Applaus]
mrd
komplett
man sieht hier eine sehr glückliche spd
zwei wahlsiegerin und ein wahlsieger und
alle zusammen haben zustande gebracht
was wir lange angestrebt haben nämlich
eine starke sozialdemokratische partei
die den auftrag kriegt die regierung zu
führen in berlin in schwerin in
mecklenburg vorpommern und auch hier in
der bundesrepublik deutschland
die wählerinnen und wähler haben auch
sehr klar gesprochen sie haben gesagt
wer die nächste regierung bilden soll
sie hat drei parteien gestärkt die
sozialdemokratische partei die grünen
und die fdp und deshalb ist das der
sichtbare auftrag den die bürger norm
bürger dieses landes formuliert haben
diese drei sollen auch die nächste
regierung führen
und auch das kann und muss hier gesagt
werden cdu und csu haben nicht nur
erheblich an stimmen verloren sondern
sie haben tatsächlich auch die
botschafter bürgern und bürger bekommen
sie sollen jetzt nicht mehr in der
regierung sein sondern in die opposition
gehen
der auftrag an uns ist jetzt auch das zu
tun was die bürgerinnen und bürger sich
wünschen nicht eigene befindlichkeiten
in den vordergrund zu stellen sondern
eine gute regierung zu führen die die
wichtigsten weichenstellungen für die
20er jahre auf den weg bringt wir es
schaffen dass mehr respekt in unserer
gesellschaft herrscht wie wir es
schaffen die industrielle modernisierung
unseres landes zustande zu kriegen und
wie wir es schaffen dass wir den
menschengemachten klimawandel aufhalten
drei große aufgaben die noch verstärkt
werden durch die aufgabe deutschlands
dafür zu sorgen dass wir ein starkes
souveränes europa bekommen wenn man die
programme aller parteien die von den
wählern und wlan zusätzliche stimmen
bekommen haben anschaut dann sieht man
dass es genügend schnittmengen gibt dies
auch zustande zu bringen aber jetzt ist
pragmatismus und führungskunst gefragt
und es geht natürlich auch darum dass
man mit guter ruhe und guter klarheit
das zustande bringt denn doch das
erwarten die bürgerinnen und bürger von
uns
ich bin sehr dankbar und sehr berührt
von der großen zustimmung für mich und
für die sozialdemokratische partei und
wir werden das was die bürgerinnen und
bürger und salz auftrag gegeben haben
umsetzen schönen dank
vielen dank liebe olaf liebe franziska
liebe saskia lieber norbert liebe
genossinnen und genossen liebe
unterstützung und unterstützer liebe
gäste zunächst möchte ich ganz herzlich
olaf scholz gratulieren und unserer spd
in deutschland zu diesem wahlsieg es war
eine spannende bundestagswahl die
bürgerinnen und bürger mussten erstmals
darüber entscheiden wer zukünftig das
land führen soll und das ergebnis ist
klar die spd ist wahlsieger die
bürgerinnen und bürger haben olaf scholz
ihr vertrauen ausgesprochen und wir
wissen aus allen befragungen die
bürgerinnen und bürger wollen dass olaf
scholz der nächste bundeskanzler von
deutschland wird und das muss er auch
werden
und deshalb liegt auch bei ihm und der
spd ganz klar
der regierungsauftrag deutschland
braucht eine gute stabile regierung für
wirtschaft soziales und umwelt und
deutschland braucht vor allem ein
kanzler der das vertrauen der
bevölkerung bekommen hat und der es kann
und der zukünftige kanzler soll olaf
scholz sein
mein glückwunsch geht auch an franziska
giffey malu dreyer und ich haben uns
immer gewünscht dass wir im kreise der
ministerpräsidenten nicht allein nur
zwei frauen blei bleiben und ich freue
mich sehr dass wir zukünftig mit drei
sozialdemokratischen ministerpräsidenten
in dieser mpk gute politik machen liebe
franziska herzlichen glückwunsch zum
wahlsieg auch der berliner spd
[Applaus]
und ich freue mich natürlich dass die
bürgerinnen und bürger gestern in
mecklenburg vorpommern ein klares
bürgervotum gesprochen haben für die spd
in mecklenburg-vorpommern für meine
arbeit als ministerpräsidentin ich bin
stolz darauf ministerpräsidentin des
schönsten bundeslandes in deutschland zu
sein und bin sehr dankbar den
bürgerinnen und bürgern dass sie gestern
ein klares votum dafür ausgesprochen
haben dass die spd die stärkste kraft im
land bleibt und dass ich meine arbeit
als ministerpräsident in dieses
wunderbaren bundeslandes fortsetzen kann
vielen dank
ich möchte mich ganz herzlich bei den
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern hier
im willy-brandt-haus bedanken vor zwei
es ist für mich ein bewegender moment
vor zwei jahren ich war das letzte mal
vor zwei jahren im willy-brandt-haus als
ich mein kommentar im parteivorsitz
wegen der krebserkrankung niederlegen
musste das war ein schwerer gang ich
hatte kaum zeit mich bei euch zu
verabschieden und eigentlich hatte ich
auch nie vor mich zu verabschieden
ich bin sehr froh dass ich heute wieder
hier sein darf dass sich den wahlsieg
aus dem nordosten mitgebracht habe und
ich möchte der partei danken allen die
in dieser zeit immer an unserer seite
waren und ich möchte vor allem den
mitarbeitern mitarbeitern danken wir
alle wissen wir haben nicht immer hier
gestanden mit drei wahlsiegen ihr habt
immer durchgehalten habt auch in
schwierigen zeiten toll gekämpft für
unsere partei mit unserer partei und
deshalb ist das heute ein wunderbarer
tag für die sozialdemokratie in
deutschland und auch für alle die hier
im willy-brandt-haus kurs halten
herzlichen dank
ja lieber olaf liebe manuela wie sehr
scully über norbert wir haben eine
beispiellose aufholjagd hingelegt und
ich kann mich noch gut erinnern an die
ersten diskussionen und wie viele haben
im letzten jahr nicht für möglich
gehalten was heute hier zu feiern ist
und was wir geschafft haben zusammen
viele haben das nicht für möglich
gehalten und dieses ergebnis ist alles
andere als selbstverständlich und es ist
ein großer erfolg und wir haben ihnen
gemeinsam geschafft ich freue mich sehr
und danke euch ein dass wir das
gemeinsam geschafft haben
die spd hat einen klaren
regierungsauftrag überall in deutschland
bekommen und ich habe oft in diesem
wahlkampf mit bürgerinnen und bürgern
darüber diskutiert werden wohl der
richtige wäre fürs kanzleramt
und eines konnten wir deutlich machen
das hat auch die menschen überzeugt olaf
scholz kann dass davon sind wir zutiefst
überzeugt
und
ich freue mich sehr dass wir eine gute
zusammenarbeit haben zwischen den
bundesländern die wir beide manuela und
ich dann vertreten und die in der
bundesregierung als unserer
bundeskanzler der bundesrepublik
deutschland wir sind stolz darauf dass
du das geschafft hast gemeinsam mit uns
allen lieber olaf herzlichen glückwunsch
und für
für berlin gar nicht sagen wir hatten
gestern ja den spannendsten wahlabend
weil das am ende dann doch nicht ganz
von anfang an klar war aber wir haben es
geschafft wir sind stärkste kraft
geworden und wir haben diesen auftrag
und wir werden verantwortungsvoll damit
umgehen damit berlin soziale und
demokratische sichere stadt lebenswerte
metropole und zukunftsfähige weltstadt
berlin bleibt und sich auch noch
weiterentwickeln kann denn wir haben die
chance und wir alle sind hier in berlin
es ist eine der attraktivsten und
teuersten städte der welt und wir haben
alles potenzial das die 2020er jahre
hier dazu führen dass berlin einer der
bedeutendsten wirtschaft technologie
kultur und kreativ standorte in europa
wird und dass wir das ganze sozial und
demokratisch machen dass alles was wir
tun auch die großen herausforderungen um
den klimawandel zu bewältigen darum
müssen wir uns kümmern aber dass wir das
tun indem wir soziale gerechtigkeit bei
jeder entscheidung nicht nur mit denken
sondern auch umsetzen und das ist unser
auftrag und den werden wir gemeinsam
erfüllen ich danke euch dafür
ja liebe
manuela liebe
franziska lieber olaf mit euch haben wir
drei verdiente wall siegerinnen und
sieger des gestrigen abends vor uns
stehen und wir gratulieren euch ganz
herzlich und
ich darf gleichzeitig sagen liebe
freundinnen und freunde
dieser erfolg hat noch nie auf so vielen
schultern innerhalb der partei und um
die partei herumgelegen wir haben es
geschafft eine einheit zu sein wir haben
menschen gehabt die an der spitze stehen
die die frontleute sind denen die
menschen vertrauen die das bündeln was
wir als partei gemeinsam erarbeitet
haben wir haben in der fläche erlebt an
wie viel stellen wir in den wahlkreisen
auf hochmotivierte vor allen dingen auch
junge leute gestoßen sind 25 27 30 aber
eben auch erfahrene kräfte wir seit
langem im bundestag sind die jetzt das
vertrauen der menschen bekommen haben
die wahlkreise gewonnen haben was vor
noch nicht allzu langer zeit unmöglich
erschienen wir haben im
willy-brandt-haus wir haben überall in
den ortsvereinen viele helferinnen und
helfer gehabt die das zustande gebracht
haben wir haben eine tolle kampagne
gehabt haben die tolle organisation
gehabt über den generalsekretär lars
klingbeil das sind alles dinge die dazu
beigetragen haben dass diese partei an
jeder stelle wo sie stand gemeinsam
stand und dass sie auch ausgestrahlt hat
wir wollen etwas gemeinsam erreichen und
dieses große vertrauen das wir gestern
gewonnen haben dass die fraktionen der
spd nach 20 jahren wieder zur stärksten
fraktion im deutschen bundestag macht
das ist ausdruck eines gemeinsamen
wollens dem eben auch die ganz große
mehrheit der bevölkerung zu stimmt
nämlich wer nicht kanzler werden soll
das ist glaube ich mit einem absturz von
8,9 prozent bei cdu und csu sehr
deutlich zum ausdruck gekommen aber das
ist auch nicht nur um eine person geht
die nicht gewollt ist sondern auch um
einen stillstand der nicht mehr gewollt
ist und gleichzeitig ist deutlich
geworden was denn gewollt ist das
gewollt ein aufbruch der die großen
aufgaben der zukunft vor allem den
klimaschutz die wirtschaftliche stärke
erhalten
infrastruktur zu bauen zusammen bringt
mit den sorgen und nöten der gegenwart
gegenwart und zukunft zusammen zu
bringen und was gewollt ist ist dass das
jemand administriert dass jemand die
richtlinien der politik bestimmt der es
kann und das ist olaf scholz und das
haben alle gestern noch einmal deutlich
gemacht olaf scholz muss vor diesem
hintergrund der nächste kanzler der
bundesrepublik deutschland seien noch
einmal einen ganz herzlichen glückwunsch
an alle drei als jemand der lange zeit
ja auch landespolitiker war weiß ich was
das für ein tolles erlebnis ist jetzt
hier zu stehen und das gemeinsam nach
vorn zu bringen und da wirklich noch mal
wieder den alten spruch zu bedienen bund
und land hand in hand das bringt was das
wird was und dafür sorgt ihr beide in
euren beiden ländern noch mal glück auf
und alles gute und noch mal ganz
herzlichen glückwunsch an olaf
lieber olaf liebe manuela liebe
franziska ich glaube die spd umrahmt
heute sehr sehr gerne drei strahlende
wahlsieger das war ein historischer tag
gestern es wird auch eine historische
wahlperiode die wir jetzt gemeinsam
gestalten wollen wir sind sehr glücklich
euch zu haben zwei starke frauen und ein
bundeskanzler die gezeigt haben dass man
dass die wählerinnen und wähler
zuversicht und dass die vertrauen in die
spd entwickeln können wieder neu
entwickeln das muss man ehrlich sagen
wir sind ja wir haben eine grandiose
aufholjagd auch hingelegt ein
historischer tag für die spd ich freue
mich wirklich sehr darauf mit euch
weiterhin sehr sehr vertrauensvoll
zusammenzuarbeiten
norbert norbert walter borjans hat das
gesagt hier stehen auch drei
regierungsaufträge wählerinnen und
wähler haben euch an die hand gegeben
die geschicke ihrer beiden bundesländer
und die geschicke deutschlands in die
hand zu nehmen mit möglichen
koalitionspartnern das ist jetzt in den
nächsten tagen auch unsere aufgabe dort
eine basis zu finden würde
zusammenarbeit die eben dem land dient
zunächst im land und ich glaube da haben
wir sehr sehr starke persönlichkeiten
jetzt hier stehen das irgendwie das
gemeinsam mit uns machen wir freuen uns
sehr auf diese arbeit
so unterwegs sie noch mal mit den
blumensträußen in die menge hätte fast
gesagt aber das ist ein klein wenig
übertrieben wie den hier klatschen sind
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter im
willy brandt haus und natürlich auch
noch die eine und andere delegation aus
den landesverbänden aus der partei die
hier heute morgen hergekommen sind zu
der sogenannten blumen übergabe für die
drei spitzenkandidaten wir stellen fest
so viel freude bei der spd war es schon
lange nicht mehr und auch so viel erfolg
nicht und vor allem auch nicht so viel
geschlossenheit die beiden
parteivorsitzenden haben es ja eben auch
noch mal betont in ihren kurzen
stellungnahmen wir werden sie im laufe
des späteren vormittags noch mal wieder
sehen die pressekonferenz der spd die
ursprünglich angekündigt war für 11 uhr
sollte sein mit saskia esken und mitten
norbert walter borjans ob sie die zeit
11 uhr schaffen da bin ich mal ein klein
wenig gespannt denn jetzt sollte
eigentlich erst mal eine
präsidiumssitzung stattfinden und das
was wir eben gesehen haben sollte
eigentlich schon um 9 uhr beginnen hat
sich schon mal um gut 15 20 minuten
verzögert am ölmarkt wir sind ja auf
jeden fall da und von daher kann hier
auch gar nichts passieren interessant
ist wir sind immer noch in der phase der
deutung dieses wahlergebnisses von
gestern und da hat olaf scholz noch mal
gesagt er sehe drei wahlgewinner nämlich
zum einen die spd die deutlich zugelegt
hat aber auch grüne und fdp hätten
zugelegt was ihre wahlergebnisse angeht
und daraus so folgert olaf scholz sind
diese drei parteien spd grüne und fdp
auch diejenigen die seiner meinung nach
im auftrag der wählerinnen und wähler
die nächste regierung bilden sollen wir
sind im anschluss an dieses themas die
wie eben gesehen haben eigentlich
verabredet mit einer der
stellvertretenden parteivorsitzenden der
spd mit sehr viel medialer die ich
erwartet die möglicherweise schon auf
dem weg hierhin ist die aber
möglicherweise sich auch noch anschaut
und deswegen schaue ich mal kurz auf den
monitor den ich hier sehe auf die bilder
die da gerade noch gemacht werden mit
den spitzenkandidaten mit
auch malu dreyer mittendrin jetzt auf
der bühne noch mal wie sie in anderen
stellvertreter und jetzt kann ich hier
auch sagen warum es apple mit iad noch
nicht bei uns steht mit auf der bühne
gemeinsam mit hubertus heil dem
stellvertretenden parteivorsitzenden da
muss ich mal schauen wen ich da noch
ausmachen kann
udo bullmann aus dem europaparlament
beispielsweise nach oben rolf mützenich
der vorsitzende der bundestagsfraktion
so und jetzt löst sich diese gruppe von
der bühne hier im atrium des willy
brandt hauses und die chance dass wir
zum versprochenen und angekündigten
interview bekommen steigt quasi
sekündlich will mich dass hier so sehe
sie stellvertretende parteivorsitzende
müsse eigentlich nur hinter der wand her
gehen die wir auch hinter mir sehen und
das sind dann im grunde nur ein paar
meter und dann könnte sie hier
eigentlich schon ankommen sie werden
sehen dass meine augen hin und wieder
auf den monitor gucken in der stillen
hoffnung dass sich die
gesprächspartnerin hinter mir sehe und
das ist sich auch schon jetzt wenn wir
uns hier live eigentlich ein klein wenig
einrichten mit dem mikrofon noch und
dann wird das auch ziemlich schnell
losgehen und ich werfe noch ein kurzer
blick auf unser bild und das steht und
dann sagte ich herzlich willkommen es
happy mediatlas schön dass es geklappt
hat jetzt um diese zeit
große begeisterung jetzt gerade über
drei wahlsiege rinnen die die spd hat
das ist ja auch nicht selbstverständlich
gewesen in den vergangenen jahren mal
ganz ehrlich wann haben sie es
tatsächlich für realistisch und möglich
gehalten dass die spd bei der
bundestagswahl vorne liegt ganz ehrlich
ganz wichtig so richtig ehrlich also so
stück für stück für stück nach vorne
ging mit dem prozentpunkten und wie auch
gemerkt haben dass wir mit unseren
themen und auch mit olaf schon der olaf
scholz hat sich das vertrauen der
menschen dann auch haben und als
natürlich auch die werte von olaf scholz
so wahnsinnig nach oben ging da wusste
man muss die partei noch ein bisschen
nachziehen aber das war so ein moment
glaube ich haben sich bei uns eigentlich
schalter umgelegt und dann haben wir nur
noch auf sieg gespielt und das heißt
aber auch im frühjahr und dem frühsommer
war die wahrscheinlichkeit doch auch bei
ihnen oder die einschätzung eher und
nicht so dramatisch großen sondern es
wurde zwar oder oder gerade olaf scholz
hat ja immer vermittelt klar wir kriegen
das schon hin und wir schaffen das nur
auf diesem weg aber so die ganz grosse
überzeugung sei noch nicht da gewesen zu
sein was heißt überzeugung auf jeden
fall haben die umfragewerte waren klar
wir hatten wir stecken mitten in corona
werden zu wenig impfstoff die menschen
mit ganz anderen dingen beschäftigt war
schon so dass dieses nicht herauskommen
aus den von dem 15 16 prozent das war
natürlich schon eine harte zeit aber wir
haben kurs gehalten wir haben an unsere
inhalte geglaubt vor allem haben wir
alle an roland scholz geglaubt und dann
gemeinsam stück für stück dafür gekämpft
es zeigt sich auch dass sich das dann
auch lohnt sie haben recht es war harte
arbeit und von daher freuen wir uns
natürlich umso mehr über diesen erfolg
den mädels fahren viele haben
interessiert beobachtet und dann auch
gestaunt wie es der spd tatsächlich
gelungen ist auf kurs zu bleiben wie sie
es gerade beschrieben haben diese
geschlossenheit auch tatsächlich
durchzuhalten auch in diesen tatsächlich
schwierigen monaten als ich so gar
nichts bewegt hat und man immer von 15%
keller gesprochen hat oder von einer
zementierten umfragelage was hat den
ausschlag gegeben dass die spd zusammen
geblieben ist das kann ja nicht alleine
ein paar kanzlerkandidaten gelegenheit
das war tatsächlich die vorarbeit davor
sie haben hier erlebt was nach letzten
bei der bundestagswahl war da haben wir
ja schon einen prozess eingeleitet
kommission eingerechnet
innerparteilichen im prozess gestartet
wir haben viele viele diskussionen
miteinander geführt die ganzen debatten
camps inhaltliche themen wie schaffen
wir es tatsächlich dass wir erstmal dass
wir selber dann schon mit welchen themen
wo wir auch auf volle müssen ganz klar
hartz4 das war eine wunde in der seele
der spd und so hat er gemacht hat andrea
nahles hat wirklich eine unglaublich
große vorarbeit geleistet und wir haben
ein stück für stück unsere inhaltlichen
themen ganzen baustellen die über die
jahre offen geblieben sind die haben wir
stück für stück
seine abgebaut dann haben ein starkes
programm gemeinsam erarbeitet und dann
starken kannst also es ist nicht von
heute auf morgen gekommen sondern es ist
harte arbeit wo viele daran beteiligt
gewesen sind und hat aber auch
wahnsinnig viel spaß gemacht um ehrlich
zu sein die rolle der beiden
parteivorsitzenden haben sie wenn ich
jetzt richtig aufgepasst hat mich so
richtig deutlich hervorgehoben oder wie
viel zeit habe ich heute noch
[Gelächter]
natürlich hat es immer etwas auch mit
führung zu tun und aber saß kam es genau
geht weiter bei uns haben von anfang an
ganz klar gemacht nicht nur sie als
doppelspitze sind ein team sondern wir
alle sind ein team und wir alle sind ein
teil sozusagen dieser dieser dieser
arbeit die vor uns liegt aber auf der
anderen seite dann auch natürlich auch
ein teil des erfolges und von daher
gebührt natürlich allen dank und respekt
vor allem dann auch die partei auch auf
der einen seite dann auch mit zudem
stellen sich das ja immer so einfach vor
aber sind halt eben knapp 400.000
mitglieder die auch in irgendeiner form
beteiligt werden wollen mitgenommen
werden führt wollen und von da ist es
unglaublich wichtig was auch insgesamt
auch in der partei dennoch passiert und
das wieder auf ihren beitrag dazu leiste
und das machen die beiden auf jeden fall
auch abschließend was muss die sbb
bieten um grüne und fdp zu gewinnen für
eine ampelkoalition
ehrlich gesagt das ist ja nicht wie hier
auf dem orientalischen basar wer bietet
sozusagen mehr so kann es ja auch nicht
sein wir haben ganz ganz große
herausforderung die vor uns liegen und
allen ist das im grunde genommen klar
wir müssen unsere wirtschaft umbauen wir
wissen wir müssen im bereich erneuerbare
energien voran kommen wir wissen wir
müssen den klimawandel stoppen wir haben
aber auch nach kona wahnsinnig viel zu
tun aus unserem gesundheitssystem an
geht aber auch ins alberne sozialere
politik zu machen und jener der bereit
ist und nur darum geht es jeder der
bereit ist in den nächsten vier jahren
verantwortung für dieses land und für
europa zu übernehmen die sind herzlich
eingeladen mit uns gemeinsam gespräche
zu führen und darauf wird das jetzt in
den nächsten tagen angekommen
herzlichen dank dass sie bei uns gewesen
sind in live bei phoenix an diesem
montagvormittag an dem die nachlese zur
bundestagswahl stattfindet und so
langsam richtig fahrt aufnimmt michael
krons macht weiter in unserem wahlstudio
im reichstagsgebäude